[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to the sixth episode
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Franscec Campoy,
and I'm here with Mark.
Hey, Mark.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Back to San Francisco.
Very excited to be back.
MARK: We're in the same
place at the same time.
It's very exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's something new.
Yeah.
So today we have a
very exciting episode.
We're going to be talking
with Ilya Grigorik.
MARK: Yes.
Very excited about this,
talking about HTTP/2 and HTTP/2
on the Google Cloud
Platform, hot topic.
It's going to be really good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's going to be really,
really interesting.
There's a lot of really
interesting things.
Not only about HTTP/2.
But we're going to also
be discussing QUIC,
and cool things that people
are trying to do with HTTP.
I'm very excited about that.
MARK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
before that, we're
going to be discussing about
the cool thing of the week.
So what is the cool
thing of the week?
MARK: Oh, I like this.
I'm admittedly not a
particular Minecraft user.
But I do love this whole space.
I think it's really creative.
A gentleman by the
name of Steve Slocum
came up with Cubecraft,
which is a lovely way
to visualize what pods are
running inside your Kubernetes
cluster inside Minecraft.
It's well worth
watching the video.
Its open source code.
It's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I've seen the video too.
I think it's really amazing.
I'm really looking forward
to more people collaborating
in that.
Because if you're able
to include that in a game
where you could actually be
killing hostile or killing
pods and seeing how they get
rescheduled somewhere else,
that could be such
an amazing thing.
MARK: Yeah.
It would be so much fun.
And then you kill one, it comes
back up, and you kill one,
and it comes back up.
It'd be great.
I could really, really like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah.
So we will put the length of
the video in the Github Repo
on the show notes,
that's for sure.
MARK: Wonderful.
Well, it sounds like
then why don't we
get stuck into our interview?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go for that.
MARK: Brilliant.
So we are joined today by the
wonderful and illustrious Ilya
Grigorik.
Thank you very much
for joining us today.
Did I manage to
pronounce your name right
is probably the first
question I need to ask.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes, you did.
But wonderful.
And was the other one?
MARK: Illustrious.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Illustrious.
MARK: Yes.
I do like my adjectives.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Such a great word.
MARK: So yes.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We're very excited to
sit down and have a chat
with you about HTTP/2 and how it
affects Google Cloud Platform.
Before we get into
that, why don't you
give us a bit of a background
on you and what you do
and your position here at Google
and all that sort of fun stuff.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure thing.
So first of all,
thank you for inviting
me to join us to talk about
this, about a topic that's near
and dear to my heart that
I've been working on for
a while, SPDY and
HTTP/2 in particular.
So I'm at the [INAUDIBLE],
also within Google.
I sit not very
far from you guys.
I could probably wave at you
in the adjacent building.
And I work with the
Chrome team, or have
been working for
a while, and also
been working with the Make the
World Fast game here at Google.
And our mission has always
been to try and figure out
how to make the internet faster
as a whole, and of course
make Chrome faster,
and Google products.
And part of that was
the speedy effort that
started back and in around
2009, later graduated to HTTP/2,
and now we're doing
exciting things with QUIC.
So lots of exciting
things there.
MARK: Well, awesome.
Well, OK.
So you mentioned three things
there, which is kind of fun.
You mentioned SPDY,
you mentioned HTTP/2,
you mentioned QUIC.
Why don't we start
with the first one?
So what was SPDY, what was that?
And we can probably
continue on from there.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure.
So when we started working
on Chrome within Google,
one of the things that
we realized very early on
is that the current web
pages that we're building
are much more complicated
than what the HP protocol was
originally designed for.
So the protocol that the
web is built on today
was more or less standardized
10 years ago, even actually
more so back in 1999.
And since then, we've started
building much more complicated
and interesting applications.
We went from pages
to applications
that fetch hundreds of
resources and all the rest.
So when the effort to
start working on Chrome
kicked off in around 2007,
2008, we very quickly
realized that,
first of all, speed
is one of the tenets of Chrome.
We want to focus on speed.
And we identified HTTP as one
of the primary bottlenecks,
where just the
number of connections
that you had to manage,
it's inefficient
both on the server
and the client.
And we were really
limited in the parallelism
for how many resources we could
fetch, what kind of signals
we can communicate
to the server to help
prioritize how the data is
returned, and all the rest.
So that was the genesis of SPDY,
where we took us aback and just
looked at what could
we do to HTTP to help
reduce or eliminate
some of the bottlenecks.
So the basic
insights were, well,
if we add things like framing,
such that we can split messages
instead of having
one message occupy
the entire connection, which is
how the HTTP/1 protocol works,
where you send the
request, you have
to wait for the entire
response before you
can send the next request.
What if we could actually send
multiple requests and responses
over the same connection?
So that framing.
Then we looked at, well,
what about prioritization?
So it turns out that
modern applications
are both smart and complicated.
Things like, as you
start scrolling,
it would be nice if
we could reprioritize
things-- like, say, an image
scrolls out of the uPort.
It'd be nice to let to
server know that hey,
this is maybe not as
important as it was before.
This is no longer visible.
Or even simpler
things, like, well, I
need this JavaScript file before
this image file because it's
blocking rendering.
That's not something you could
actually express in a protocol
before.
So we started looking
at priorities.
And then there's
another feature that
has to do with compression.
So we realized that
the headers of HTTP
are always transferred
in plain text.
They're not compressed.
HTTP allows the bodies
to be compressed.
But the GET header is
the user agent's string,
and all those things are always
transferred uncompressed.
And frankly, they're kind
of redundant oftentimes.
And there's a lot of that
data going back and forth.
So if we could
compress that data,
that would also speed
up the protocol.
And then building
on those primitives,
there's additional things
that went into the protocols
to just make it more efficient.
And that was effectively
the genesis of SPDY.
The Chrome team
implemented that,
or started
experimenting with it.
They started implementing
it also on the server.
So our Google servers in Chrome
were some of the first ones
to test this out and gather some
data from out the wild to see,
does this work?
And lo and behold, it
turns out that it did work.
It actually helped some of
our services quite a bit.
So we took that proposal to
IETF and started the discussion,
around what can we
do in the space?
SPDY is just one way of
tackling this problem.
And after some back
and forth, the IETF
started a new effort
to define HTTP/2,
and actually adopted
SPDY, which at the time
was draft to a version
too of the protocol
as a starting point.
And then the working
group took over,
and we continued to contribute
to it and work with the team
there.
And that effectively
became HTTP/2.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So what you're saying is
that at the beginning,
HTTP/2 was basically SPDY, which
was a Google product-- a Google
project., sorry.
But from there it kept on
evolving to become a standard.
What are the main differences
between SPDY and HTTP/2?
What was added or
removed from it?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So there's
a lot of low level details,
like the framings is
slightly different.
If you care about how the
bits are aligned on the wire,
there's quite a
few subtle changes.
We change the definitions
on the frames.
We changed how the
prioritization scheme works.
So for example, in SPDY, we
had a fairly simple model where
you could just assign a weight.
In HTTP/2, it's much
more comprehensive.
It allows you to express
both weights and dependencies
between resources.
We've done some additional
work on server push,
which is something we
actually haven't talked about.
But in a HTTP/2, we
have this new capability
where, in response
to a single request,
the server can actually push
multiple responses back.
So a use case here would
be, hey, you came and asked
for the index.html.
But I know that you're going
to ask for the JavaScript
file and the style sheet.
So why should I wait for
another round trip for you
to just come back to me
and ask me for this thing?
So here.
Just have it.
So that's server push.
And there's some
other kind of cleanups
in all the rest that was added.
So the HTTP/2
draft, or that work,
I think it went through--
I don't want to lie,
but it was definitely more
than a dozen iterations.
And it was actually
really, really good
because unlike a lot
of the other protocols,
this was being developed
and tested in the field.
So very early on, of course,
we had Chrome support.
Firefox also supported SPDY.
IE and Safari also
jumped on board.
So while we were testing
HTTP/2, we were actually very,
very data driven.
So we had these meetings
every three or four months
where we would come back
and do interrupt testing
between all the browsers
and the major servers.
Of course, there
was Google, there
was Twitter, there was
Facebook, and others
that were experimenting
with this stuff.
So we could make
hypotheses and say, hey,
we would like to
propose this feature.
Instead of just
arguing about it,
we could actually
try and implement it,
see what the data says, and then
come back to the drawing board
and say what worked
and what didn't.
So by the time the HTTP/2
spec was actually finalized
and went out as a
standard, we already
had implementations
in all the browsers.
We had very good
implementations in many servers,
including open source versions.
So it was probably one of
the best tested protocols
that we've released
in a long time
amongst all the
different stacks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So from the
beginning, we already
had support for SPDY and
HTTP/2 on some Google services
and Chrome.
And other people
also jumped into it.
When did we start having
that kind of support
in other Google services,
like specially Google Cloud
Platform?
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's
a good question.
I don't know the exact date.
But I can say that, of
course most, if not all,
of our services at
Google, actually
are served by more or
less the same front
end, which is our Google
Front End-- or GFE, as we
call it an internally.
And the GFE was where we've
implemented SPDY support.
So the support for
SPDY was effectively
enabled for any and
all Google service,
as long as they use HTTPS.
This is actually one thing
we haven't talked about.
But in order to
use SPDY in HTTP/2,
you have to use HTTPS
because the negotiation
for the protocol happens when
the TLS handshake is done.
That's how the client advertises
that, hey, I support HTTP/2,
and the server picks that.
And I believe, actually, that
we had silent support for SPDY
for a very long time,
especially in places
like App Engine,
where we actually
haven't advertised it much.
But we were certainly the first
platform that supported it.
So if you happen to run your
service on top of App Engine
and with HTTPS, you probably
didn't even know it,
but you were already
SPDY-enabled,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So one more reason
to use HTTPS on top of security
is that it will be even faster.
That's nice.
MARK: It will be even faster.
So OK.
So you're extending
on from there.
It leads us quite nicely into--
so people are saying, yep,
HTTP/2's awesome.
I want the extra speed.
You know it's going to
make my sights faster.
How do I get HTTP/2 now on
like Google Cloud Platform?
What do I need to do
to get that enabled?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So actually, I think that's
an even better question for me
to phrase to you guys.
You know it probably
even better than I do.
But depending on
how you set it up,
you need to make sure
that, first of all,
we said HTTPS, right?
That's point one.
Once you have HTTPS,
you need to make sure
that whatever you're
using is able to negotiate
HTTP/2 on your behalf.
And then this question of how's
that routed to your back end?
So if you're using something
like a TCP load balancer,
then you have to
terminate the HTTPS
and have a server that is
capable of talking HTTP/2.
Whereas if your using
the HTTPS load balancer,
which is HTTP aware,
then it will do that work
on your behalf.
And I think we have a
pretty nice diagram--
MARK: We do.
ILYA GRIGORIK: --on our blog
that that shows all of that.
MARK: That might have been a
leading question considering
that you and I worked
on that blog together.
But that's fine.
I'm happy with that.
That's totally fine.
So yeah.
It's pretty cool.
You put a load balancer in
front of it, you go HTTPS,
you get HTTP/2 support, you
use App Engine, you use HTTPS,
you get HTTP/2 support.
I really like this.
I think it's actually really,
really, really powerful.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So actually, I think
this highlights something
very important.
So SPDY and HTTP/2 do not
change anything semantically
about how HTTP works.
It's all the same methods,
it's all the same headers,
it's all the rest.
So when I said
earlier that if you're
running on HTTPS
on an app engine,
you're probably running SPDY
and you didn't even know it,
that's very important.
So even today you're thinking,
so how do I enable HTTP/2?
It's like, well,
switch over to HTTPS.
Put a load balancer on a server
that is able to speak HTTP/2.
And your application will work.
There is nothing extra
that you need to do.
Now, there are things
that you could perhaps
do within your
application to take
better advantage of some of the
things that HTTP/2 provides.
But that's a whole
different matter.
MARK: No.
That's great.
So if they want to
take advantage--
we talked a little
bit about server push,
like pushing up assets.
Are there any other
things that people
might be able to take advantage
of they might want to?
ILYA GRIGORIK:
Well, I think this
is where we get back or get
into what kind of things
you can do to get the
most out of HTTP/2.
So HTTP/2 removes a lot of the
bottlenecks that we previously
had to work around, things
like concatenated files.
And for the most part, those
primarily because the requests,
having multiple
independent requests
was just very costly from
a latency perspective.
So we would take all of our like
beautiful modular JavaScripts
and CSS and put it into
one file and say, here.
Here's a workaround.
Just fetch this one big
blob of data, which is fine.
It works, except that
it does run into issues
with things like caching.
So now your designer comes
along, changes one color,
and then all of a sudden
your entire style sheet
is invalidated.
Could you have split that
such that the things that
are changing rapidly are
small, such that next time it's
updated you just
update that one file?
That's fewer bytes
for the client
to fetch when they
come back to your site.
It also means that the
content is fetched faster.
So it's less load, it's faster
load, it's a win all around.
So now you can actually start
thinking about that and saying,
well, I probably already put in
some automation in place that
puts all the files
together into one bundle.
Maybe I want to
undo all of that.
I probably don't want to
ship hundreds of files
because that has
its own limitations.
But dozens is probably a
very good kind of safe spot.
So that's one very
concrete example.
The other one is server
push, as you mentioned.
So this is actually
something that developers
have been using unknowingly.
This is very
similar to inlining.
So with inlining, it's kind
of a similar hack that says,
well, maybe the
request is so small,
or I don't want
you to come back.
So I'm just going to embed
it in another resource.
I'm going to take
this image, and just
basic C foreign code it,
and put into HTML such
that you don't even
have to ask me for it.
But that's what server
push accomplishes well,
except server push, when
the resource is pushed,
it actually goes into the cache.
So it's separate
from the HTML file.
So that resource can be
reused across multiple files,
it can be invalidated,
all the same things.
So that's another example.
And for server push,
I think we have
some exciting news coming up.
Maybe once this
podcast goes live,
that will show you
how to use that
on App Engine and
other places as well.
So I'm really
excited about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds pretty exciting.
So one of the things that
I had to deal before with
and I didn't really
enjoy was the fact
that to serve better
a bunch of images,
I had to put them
all in a single image
and then do CSS
tricks with that.
Does that mean that with HTTP/2
that is not needed anymore?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So it's the exact same issue
as the JavaScript and CSS.
We have lots of small icons.
And it's just very
expensive to fetch them all
because we have effectively--
the maximum parallelism is six
connections or six requests.
And my page just happens
to have 100 icons.
That's going to
take a long time.
That's a lot of round trips.
So we put them all into one
file and then use a CSS axe.
So yeah.
This is no longer necessary
because now the server,
or the client rather, can
just send all 100 requests
over the single connection.
And then the server can respond
and interweave that data
as it wishes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is really awesome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Now,
as I said before,
if you have thousands
of images, there
are other concerns
where it may still
be useful to do some
sort of spriting.
So for example, let's say all
your icons are kind of similar.
You could actually get
much better compression
if you put some of them together
in terms of your actual image
format.
So there's some interesting
areas to explore here.
It's not just like
unbundle everything.
But at the same time, I think
that's an exception, not
the rule now.
Whereas before, as a rule
we had to put everything
into one image file, or once
CSS file, or one JavaScript.
And now that's more
of a nice pattern.
MARK: It kind of changes
their rules of thumbs
that you would
necessarily apply when you
started building this stuff.
That makes a lot of sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
This makes me think about the
demo that we'll put on the show
now for sure.
It's this HTTP demo developed
by [INAUDIBLE] from the Go team.
So basically, they
show the difference
between loading--
I think it's maybe
100 little images on
HTTP/1 versus HTTP/2.
And it's quite amazing.
The difference is
really night and day.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
And it's really important that
as you look at those images,
you try and grok
as to why that is.
And in HTTP/1
world, it's loading
slowly because we can fetch it,
at most six styles at a time.
And then there's
many round trips
to fetch all the
necessary tiles.
And with HTTP/2, the client just
sends all the requests at once.
So effectively, we're
limited by the speed
of the link between the
client and the server.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So there's a lot of
benefits from moving
from HTTP/1 to HTTP/2.
We actually came via first
that experiment that was SPDY.
What about QUIC?
You mentioned that.
What is QUIC?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So actually,
before I go to QUIC,
can I just make one
more note about SPDY?
MARK: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Of course.
MARK: Of course.
ILYA GRIGORIK: SPDY
co-evolved with HTTP/2.
SPDY was effectively the
experimental protocol
for HTTP/2.
So while we were
working in HTTP/2 spec,
we were testing things in SPDY.
And some people have a
good question of-- so
what does that mean?
Do we keep SPDY, and
do we keep the HTTP/2?
An the plan there is
to deprecate SPDY.
So we announced, or
Chrome announced,
that we will deprecate
SPDY sometime in early 2016
because we want to
encourage everybody
to shift over to HTTP/2.
And for example, when you look
at support for HTTP/2 and SPDY
across some of the new browsers,
like Edge, Microsoft Edge,
they only support HTTP/2 now.
So if you've been running
SPDY, start looking at HTTP/2.
And the good news
is there's actually
very good service support now.
Like Nginx and Apache all have
support, App Engine, of course,
and all the load balancers and
all the rest on Google Cloud
Platform have it.
So just FYI, if you'be been
running SPDY, look at HTTP/2.
MARK: No.
That's a very interesting point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a fair point.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And
then for QUIC, so this
is an interesting one.
Even when we started
working on SPDY,
we knew that the moment you
address issues at the HTTP/2
layer, you're going to run into
issues at the next layer down,
which is TCP.
And TCP had some behaviors,
like head of line blocking,
that are not optimal.
So for example, if
you have packet loss,
because TCP guarantees
in order delivery,
if you lose just one packet,
even though you may have other
packets already
sitting in the buffer,
you cannot deliver them because
you need to retransmit that
first packet that was dropped
such that you can guarantee
an order delivery.
So this seems like, eh, so what?
But in practice, it can
actually be quite bad,
because if you think about
sending 100 requests out,
and then everything is stalled
in that one last packet
when you could have
been processing
something else, that's
sub-optimal, so just
one example.
Other examples would be
things like mobility or mobile
connections where sometimes
TCP-- or, are not sometimes--
oftentimes, actually, TCP
misunderstands the behavior
of some of the mobile
networks and considers
it to be like packet loss
where it's really not.
So it has sub-optimal behaviors.
So looking at all that,
we knew that at some point
we're going to have to dig
a little bit deeper and try
to change TCP or go
some other route.
But when we start
working on SPDY,
that was frankly a bit
too much to tackle at once
at both layers.
So we focused on the HTTP layer.
And then as that migrated
towards the ITF working group
and HTTP where it
kicked off, we started
looking at the next layer down.
So effectively, QUIC
is HTTP/2 over UDP.
MARK: Wow.
Interesting.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
And you can imagine
how that can be very
interesting and complicated.
So we've tried, and
we do, actually.
We have a team
within Google that
works on TCP on Linux
Kernel and other things.
So we've upstreamed many
improvements over time.
But one thing we learned
is that TCP is actually
very slow in terms
of the update cycle,
getting support
out in the clients,
rolling out a new server, and
all the rest, which is frankly
for a good reason because
there's so much writing
on it that the
last thing you want
is crazy experiments
running out in the wild
and causing networks
to collapse.
So the people that maintain all
those branches-- and plus you
have all the hardware with
baked-in implementations of it
that you frankly can't
even update at this point.
And UDP offers a
very simple interface
that provides no
primitives whatsoever
in terms of reliability
and all the rest.
And that's something that
we could experiment with.
So with that we
started with that.
And we started
effectively reimplementing
some of the basic
primitives of TCP,
but also adding hooks
for new capabilities
that we could explore, so
things like pluggable congestion
control.
So maybe we can use different
congestion control strategy
for mobile networks
or 2G networks
then when you're on Google Fiber
and you have a gigabit link.
Those have very, very
different characteristics
in terms of how
we want to handle
congestion and other things.
We also spent a lot of time
looking at eliminating latency
during the handshake.
So we talked about
requiring TLS for HTTP/2.
It turns out that
once you deploy
HTTP/2, because you don't
need the extra connections,
it actually mitigates a lot
of the latency costs of TLS.
So TLS handshake
itself adds two round
trips of latency
for the handshake
if it's not optimized.
And if you've
optimized it well, it's
another round trip, which
sometimes can be significant.
But that latency
is offset by HTTP/2
because it does not
require as many connections
and you amortize that cost over
the lifetime of the connection.
With QUIC, we actually
wanted to get to a zero RTT
handshake, a secure
handshake, where
we can guarantee that
it's always encrypted,
but we can send application
data in the first round trip.
So I can just start
talking to the server
and immediately send
unencrypted data such
that there is no
penalty cost whatsoever
for using encrypted sections.
So that was another big change.
And this work has been going
on for a while within Chrome.
I think we're on version
23 or 24 of QUIC protocol.
Some of those changes, of
course, smaller than others.
But I think it speaks volumes
that we are on version 25,
and in the meantime, 0 new
versions of TCP have shipped.
MARK: So how much faster
is QUIC than HTTP/2?
Obviously, it seems
to be determined
in certain situations.
But ballparkish?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
it really depends.
Actually, the same
question applies to HTTP/2.
How much faster is
HTTP/2 than HTTP/1?
And the answer
there is it really
depends on your application.
It depends on where
your users are
based on the characteristics
and all the rest.
We do have some
numbers that we've
shared for some of
the Google products.
I think this is data
from maybe a year
or so ago where we've
seen improvements
for anywhere between
30% and 50% in terms
of latency, overall latency
for our own products.
Now, if all you do is
you take an HTTP/2 server
and replace a current server
with an HTTP/2 server,
I can't guarantee
any sort of like,
oh, it will go two times faster.
It really depends on how well
your server is implemented
and how you're currently
serving your application.
How many third
parties do you have?
Are you concatenating
your files?
Are they unbundled
and all the rest?
So there's a lot
of gotchas in here.
And then to answer
your question on QUIC,
when we compare it to
HTTP/2, once again,
it really depends on the
scenarios that we look at.
The areas where we found
most success so far
are actually in some of
the developing markets,
like India, where we
have very slow users
with very slow connections.
And we've shared some numbers.
And I can give you guys the
links to the Chromium blog
that has more details on this.
For example, YouTube saw
a significant improvement
in the latency, reducing
the number of rebuffers,
and improvement somewhere in
the range of 20% to 30% again
for the latency of
those users because they
were able to eliminate some of
those retransmissions, delays,
and other things.
So there's no one number that
I can give you that like, oh,
QUIC is X percent faster.
MARK: What?
No silver bullet?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
No, but at least
that's very interesting
that in the connections are
the slowest, that's
where we're going
to get the best improvement.
That's really interesting.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Well, yeah.
So at a very high level, the
benefits that we're seeing,
you can think of it as kind
of a long tail distribution
for a lot of the
connections in terms
of latency and all the rest.
And what QUIC really
helps us with,
at least based on our
current observations,
is to rein in those
sales and chop them off
because we can explicitly
guard for those things
and implement smarter behaviors
for bigger, slower networks.
So it allows us to be much
more-- to just eliminate
a class of really bad
behaviors, which is actually
very important for
a lot of people
and for a lot of applications.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK: No, that's good.
So just to be clear as
well, so Google is currently
experimenting with
QUIC on the GFEs
and on Google Cloud Platform.
Is that something that's
being experimented on,
I'm guessing within
Chrome as well?
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's right.
Yeah.
So we have an
implementation in Chrome.
And if you're curious,
you can actually
just pull up the Chromium
source and look at the code.
There's a toy server
in there as well
that I think was just
built for small testing.
And then our GFE, again,
also implements QUIC,
just as we did with SPDY.
So most of the SPDY-- sorry.
Most of the Google services
are already speaking QUIC.
One thing that you could
do-- and I recommend
doing this-- is you can
go to the Chrome store
and search for--
what's it called?
I think it's the SPDY Extension.
MARK: Yeah, the plug-in
that shows the stuff.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And
what it'll do is
it'll show you like
a little lightning
bolt in your navigation bar.
It'll show green when you're
talking to a server that's
HTTP/2, and I'll show red when
it's talking to a QUIC server.
And if you install
that and you start
navigating to your
favorite Google products,
you will very quickly find that
it's showing the red bolt quite
often.
And that's because most of
our services like YouTube
are already being
served over UDP.
So if you're watching
this or something else
on YouTube in Chrome,
chances are it's actually
talking UDP today.
MARK: Yeah.
Yeah.
I've got that installed.
It's actually really fun
to go around the internet
and have a look.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
installing it right now.
That sounds very interesting.
MARK: That's really great.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So speaking of not advertising
these things too much,
I think the same will happen if
you open your App Engine app.
And that's running over HTTPS.
You'll probably see a
red bolt, which tells you
that your application
is being served
over QUIC for the
browsers that support it.
MARK: Yes, for the
Yeah.
I think I remember this.
And I think I had to tweak a
couple of things inside Chrome
to get QUIC enabled in the build
that I was running a while ago.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I just
tried it with normal Chrome,
our own page, which is
hosted by App Engine.
And I get HTTP/2.
And we didn't do anything
to it, so that's nice.
MARK: That is nice.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yep.
And so QUIC is already
enabled by default in Chrome.
We do run experiments.
We always have a
group, a random group
that we hold back just for
AB testing and other things.
So it may be the case
that if you try to open it
and you don't see it, you
may be in that lucky group.
So you can force it.
And you can override it if
you go into Chrome settings.
But just FYI.
MARK: Wonderful.
All right.
Well, before we finish
up, Ilya, is there
anything else you want
to mention, or plug,
or anything like that?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Well,
a couple of things.
First off, if you're
running on App Engine,
definitely go and
check out the blog
for-- that covers HTTP/2
and that whole flow
of which service are you using
and how do you enable HTTP/2.
Start with enabling
HTTPS, and make sure
that you have the
other things enabled.
Watch out for the
server push support.
I think that's coming soon.
It's actually already
there, I think.
We just haven't really
talked about it.
I think there's a theme here.
And then finally,
I think there's
QUIC, which lots of people
are really excited about.
So if protocol's something
that you get excited about,
then I definitely encourage you
to go read the draft on ATF.
Give us feedback, install
the extension, play with it.
And of course, if you're
running on App Engine,
then poke around and see
how it works under the hood.
MARK: Wonderful.
All right.
Well, thank you very much
for joining us today, Ilya.
That was very informative.
I really enjoyed that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
I really learned a lot today.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
Thank you, guys.
MARK: Thank you.
Thanks so much for joining us.
But we have a wonderful
question of the week.
I've seen this come
up a few times,
people looking at different
solutions for, how
do you do long running jobs,
like say a video transcoding,
image processing, maybe
even code compilation
for build systems?
And what options do they
have available to them
to do that sort of stuff
on Google Cloud Platform,
but in a cost efficient way?
There should be something there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So the obvious way to do
it would be, of course,
to just have a machine that
it's running all the time.
But the problem is
that maybe that's not
the most cost efficient way.
So if you have
something that you
can divide into
small chunks of work,
that you can retry
if something fails,
then let's imagine that
you put those tasks
in some queuing system,
like Pub/Sub for instance--
MARK: Pub/Sub would
be a great fit.
SPEAKER 1: And then
what you can do
is have a bunch of
preemptible machines.
And preemptible
VMs, basically what
it means is that those
machines could be preempted,
or in other words,
you could be asked
to stop using those
machines at some point.
But if you can retry
that task later on,
then that's not
really a big issue.
And now the cool thing is that
the cost is much, much lower.
MARK: Preemptible VMs
are up to 70% cheaper.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So that's a huge thing.
MARK: That's a good savings.
That's a good savings.
And it's pretty much
a regular machine.
They can last for up to 24
hours, which is really cool.
But yeah.
If they fall over, and you're
able to just be like, OK.
That's fine.
We'll just try again
for this thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And anyway,
if you're writing anything
that it's running
on the cloud, you
should always be aware of the
machine could fail at any time.
So basically, most
of the time you
don't need to add anything that
you had not been doing before.
MARK: Yeah.
I can totally see
this makes sense,
Pub/Sub with a preemptible
VM, pulling stuff off.
That makes so much sense.
And it could give you
some really good savings.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And actually, if
some of you might
have heard about this
really cool thing
that Google created,
MapReduce, which
is just a more sophisticated way
of doing exactly the same idea,
doing just a bunch of
jobs that could fail,
and they will be
retried and so on.
But it's much more complicated.
Running MapReduce
on preemptible VMs
is a great match,
because MapReduce
will be managing the
fact that if job fails,
there will be trial run.
So you don't need to
add anything else.
Just say, for
instance, maybe you
will have an instance group.
And that instance
then played, it
will say that VM
should be preemtible.
That's it.
Just because you say
that, you get huge saving.
MARK: You can do also
really cool stuff.
All our stuff is API driven.
So if you want to spin
these out with APIs
and manage them yourselves, you
can totally do that as well.
I've seen people do it.
It works really, really well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
lots of cool things
that you can do with preemptible
VMs, lower cost, and still
the same performance, just
if might be preemptive.
MARK: Wonderful.
Well, Fransec,
where are you going
to be in the next coming time?
You going anywhere?
It's slowing down?
It's the end of the year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
it's the end of the year.
So my next trip is
actually holidays, finally.
MARK: Oh, lovely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's pretty much it.
After that, I know
that late January I
will be going to
[INAUDIBLE] in Brussels.
MARK: Very nice.
I will be in Canada.
I will be in Vancouver towards
the end of mid-December.
on the 12th for a dev fest.
I'll be up there with a
couple other of my colleagues.
But yeah.
That's it for me as well.
So it's sort of heading
towards the end of year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
MARK: Well, thank you
once again, Francesc,
for joining me for a wonderful
episode of our podcast.
It was a delight and a
pleasure to be here with you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: As you say,
a delight and a pleasure too.
So talk to you all next week.
MARK: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]